hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to I'm on observation
Duty a new game has been released number
six it's a whole new game six new levels
I don't know what they are but I've got
the strategy if anything I feel like
this game alone is helping me to improve
my memory expansively which is not the
right adjective but you're not going to
judge me for that let me try normal if
normal's too easy then I could try hard
mode but I don't think that I want to
jump into hard mode every time I do that
in a game it works out terribly for me
so I'm not going to do that locals have
reported large quantities of anomalous
events happening at the location the
epicenter seems to be a parked
locomotive at the center of the Railway
Station a body was found inside the
train we have not yet been able to
identify the body due to the extreme
damage caused to it by what appears to
have been a gigantic blunt instrument
wielded with immense strength hope that
doesn't happen to me strange mumbling
resembling no known language has been
heard from the train numerous passengers
have reported luggage disappearances in
leaving the train with items they did
not enter the train with oky
doie I swear I I I'll I'll get that
fixed someday someday luggage Cola
cheese
sandwiches oh God too much
okay I'm just going to operate under the
assumption that I'm not going to get it
the first time which is what I usually
do
uhhuh
well
mhm things are on the floor leaves
outside vest bun bun sandwiches luggage
cheese laptop Cola shoes bag toothbrush
toothpaste monkey bear maybe I don't
know chips entrance for employees only
smile there's a reflection I need to
take note of that I can see outside the
levers are in certain positions I doubt
that would be something that would be
noted the TVs could have something on
them magazine sideways emergency exit
sign up at the top it's a bear monkey
monkey bear three buttons on the
backpack three plants up there ready to
purchase employees only there's a
menu lots of places for unsettling
things to occur
surely luggage is
yellowish uh fire
hydrant evacuation plan chips nothing
there reflection toilet is
open bun bun
oh
boy
okay it's going to be hard plunger four
rolls of toilet paper one plant by the
side of the trash can there is trash in
the trash can well that's not right I
don't think that was yeah that's what is
it just
Distortion P passenger car
no not I I don't know what that would be
reported as I don't I I don't know what
to call that
Abyss no not Abyss what would you call
that there's a freaking chair
sideways
Coast what would you call
that the chair is literally sideways
how steam smoke
lights I
I was that like
that oh there's a light in the private
car there's no way that was like that
right there's no way the chairs would
have been sideways I feel like my
God why was that that thing that that it
did luggage was that always
there Distortion Dining Car Distortion
is that I mean it's a simplified menu so
there's less but I don't know what
things would be called otherwise were
there two cups on
there I don't know that
oh
oh ah
ah something going on
there probably
not well that's
different it's an interesting mechanic I
I feel
like that might be
different
huh oh okay steam smoke in the driver's
car that's for sure that could just be a
actual engine malfunction I don't know
if that's actually terrible I don't like
this screen I don't like I don't like
what that represents we are making
progress which is good that cabinet's
open reflection good outside is good all
this is
good seems good
Wait no that's how that was it's it's
just lumpy oh God yeah I think that was
just
lumpy like they're not always going to
be obvious but some of them you know
logic
prevails I mean I don't know if that's
true
logic never prevails in this game okay
yeah hard mode would have been a bad
decision because there's no way that I
would have gone through this without
errors costing
me
oh apparently we don't need safety here
we don't need a fire extinguisher up
there where there was Smoke definitely
don't need that why is my screen so
big it's getting a neck workout just
playing this game
hey wait a minute well that's not
right really that's an emergency exit I
don't
know be light something doesn't seem
right was there always this ethereal
glow probably just a vending machine
outside or something what did I just
see was that
crazy maybe I don't know I don't know
now I'm starting to just get paranoid
which always
happens I just got this weird chill down
my spine and I don't know if it's
because my subconscious saw something
that my conscious mind missed which is a
thing that can happen you know the
feeling of being watched sometimes is
right if you are being
watched maybe that's what's different
about it is a curtain always half
open oh my God go away
bear I don't know why that was that
disturbing but
whatever
okay don't smile day wait a
minute come on
now
that's we don't don't smile
here so spooky no oh man doesn't want me
to smile whatever am I going to
do that was always like
that
[Music]
artist I haven't noticed much over here
whoa I keep thinking I'm seeing
something like little flashes of
something I don't know what it'd
be was that cup always
there
was this door always like this now I'm
just grasping at straws I don't know
what I'm doing and I don't know why I'm
doing
it bun
bun ah
oh feel like I'm missing something
instant suffering oh no I mean I've
guess if the train was moving at speed
that would be pretty instantaneous
Badness
oh no Abyss Abyss Abyss in the dining
car it's an abyss it's the abyss it's
the abyss it's the
abyss oh my god oh what is it uh
Distortion uh dining C Distortion
no wait wait okay I don't know what
these are are right away so I'm not
going to be able to know what to label
them right away so you son of a
think you can just pull one of those on
me
no
no wait wait a minute wait wasn't wasn't
that is that always just just a towel
wait a yeah I know I know I know
yeah I know I get it oh oh oh lights in
the
washroom yeah I get it I know I'm bad at
my
job see I I definitely haven't been
paying attention to anything
outside of the train there's no way that
I'm going to be able to solve
that is this always down or what even is
that I don't
know I'm getting a whole lot of nothing
over
here I'm not doing
good only 3:00 I'm I'm just now halfway
there okay all right
well okay well you win some you lose
some but at least now I'll be able to
know what I was doing yeah non only
report missing
objects I missed missing object in the
driver's car oh missing object then
extra object in the passengers and
Camera malfunction in the private car
was there a camera malfunction in the
private car all right okay well let me
get a fresh look at this so there
missing object in the passenger car
extra object in the priv car or vice
versa it's bad that I don't notice any
difference now oh the plant oh the plant
was missing in the driver's car so there
was an extra object in the passenger car
I don't know where the hell that would
have been maybe an extra row of chairs
or
something okay no no it was a camera
malfunction in the private car but
probably as soon as that happened it
game overed me God I should say things
out loud again the water bottle is blue
it has a blue
stripe
there's chips and
soda I'm going to go out it backwards
this time I'm going to go the other way
just to try to mix it up in my
head oh God
[Music]
no
hey I just looked at you and now you're
would you mess with me I don't know if
that's just a coincidence or if it's
actually messing with me like sometimes
maybe a wrong report is actually going
to create an anomaly that'd be
interesting then you'd just be
paranoid so when they were saying that
someone died in this died was died had
death imp implied upon them
had someone cast a spell of death
through a big old sledgehammer on them
like I I don't know if this should be
cordoned off or if there would be like a
big blood stain or if we're going to see
the events occur or something like
that but that'd be kind of cool they did
say that a big Burly something or other
was the one to Dish out the pain maybe
the reality is that
I'm I'm the big Burly something or other
dishing out the pain why do I feel like
something's missing here I don't think
there is but something's not right
something feels different there but I
don't know what man I'm sucking this
time I'm I'm doing
terribly I'm doing
horrendously oh wait a minute hold on a
second I saw that not many people would
but I saw it my Keen
Eye I know there's one more that was
probably one of two right now there's
one more floating around I haven't seen
yet yep I'm
dumb
I I'm really um my IQ is plummeting
brain is smoothing all the memory
benefits I talked about at the beginning
of this video are
gone and the shame don't even get me
started on the
shame oh my
God what is missing what is added what
what is anything how have I not seen
nothing how have I seen a whole lot of
nothing oh well there you are again
thanks well at least it's giving me
something see I don't know if it's just
making me paranoid to think that I'm
missing things but I don't think I am
but I don't
know how could I possibly know I guess I
could use my brain but that chance of
that happening felt like there was
magazines back there was that in the
other car might have just been in the
other car this one yeah there are
magazines back there was this bag always
that color I don't
know now I'm just clicking on
everything there's no penalty for it so
why not I hope it doesn't when I switch
cameras it doesn't apply to the next one
instead if I'm a little too quick on the
draw okay hello having a nice nap there
pal
having a good sleep
friend
good okay there's a ghost there's a
ghost there's a ghost in the passenger
car well that's
fine well okay so if that was two in a
row then maybe I'm not missing something
maybe I'm just working myself up into a
tizzy just for no reason
oh don't smile day not today my friend
not
today I think that was always that
[Music]
yeah lights in the
washroom okay they're getting kind of
active now at least this is making me
feel
better you freaking bear stop
[Music]
moving doing ever so slightly better I
think okay I'm definitely missing
something what am I
missing what am I missing
missing please tell me what am I missing
I don't
know something feel it just been too
long like how it did not be
something is that an
eyeball yeah I think that's an
eyeball yeah I think that was an
yeah good glad I spotted that any more
eyeballs anyone peeping out for us
underneath there oh that's a strange box
of ethereal
Madness
[Music]
odd all
right oh footy steps well they're
they're coming in fits and bursts
they're not pacing these out they're
coming at me hot and fast or just as
soon as I fix one they replace it with
another which is like kind of a dick
move but whatever I can handle it I'm
tough and brave and
strong definitely not smart which is the
only thing that really matters in this
game oh who kicked the shoes
over who did
[Music]
that well it seems like I'm on top of
everything I say ominously as the light
turns off for those of you wondering
like my light literally is broken but it
works enough that I just don't feel like
fixing it or replacing it cuz I can't be
bothered with something like that it
illuminates me most of the time am I
going to admonish something just because
they get 95% right and then 5% of the
time less oh God 5% of the time it
doesn't work which is even less probably
like probably 2% of the time it's on 98%
that's an
A+ you think I'm going to I'm going to
be harsh on this light
no way I'm going to recognize it for the
value that it's providing most of the
time yeah it could be 100% consistent
but you know I'm not going to ask too
much just like I hope this game doesn't
ask too much of me if I get 95% of
everything then maybe it should be a
little bit
Kinder
[Music]
law oh my God why every time when I yawn
why is it only when I'm yawning
go
[Music]
away it didn't look like the big Burly
thing that beat the dude to death so I'm
going to guess that you're not actually
a danger to me which is a terrible
assumption to make in this game I
recognize that horrible assumption to
make but I'm going to make it plant
still there cup's still there bun Bun's
still there cheese is still there bag's
still there bag still on top one bag
over there seems good emergency exit bag
monkey plans towel everything's
good cup cup is
gone good thing I just said that because
I would not have thought about the cup
if I didn't just say it out loud that's
why I got to keep
talking I mean I know I've been doing
nothing but yapping but I got to say out
loud actually stay on topic and not talk
about my life in random fits and bursts
not start going off on some rant about
lenses again although I am going to
start going on rant about lenses very
soon here cuz you
know the thing about making uh big fun
projects is that you just want to make
more big fun projects and you want to do
them better and uh part of the process
is learning all the fun intricacies
about all the toys that go into making
things like that you know what I
mean you know what I mean oh d extion in
the dining car wait was that it was a
camera malfunction meaning like I didn't
even notice that one of the cameras
wasn't even on cuz that definitely could
have been
something like if I didn't
notice that an entire camera was
gone that would really be
something oh doors open I don't like
that the doors open that is
uncomfortable please close the
door it's not even like I'm on the train
car right I'm not here am I I'm looking
through a security system that's miles
away and the safety of some security
office which we all know is the safest
place to
be
definitely something feels different in
here I don't know what but something
feels a little different I know that
suitcase was was back there but I I
something wait wasn't there something
here like in the background there I know
the car was there but I felt like
something else was
there what was going on there that's
just a shadow isn't it okay apparently I
just woke up because now everything
looks completely different and I can't
tell if I'm dreaming about what I'm
seeing or
not
uh ah get out of
[Music]
here
something's different in back
[Music]
there plant cup bon
bon uh freaking this and that and
something
else oh God close that door please close
that
[Music]
door is it just like a bunch of oal
Loopers come running in and and then fix
up everything while my back is turned
some anomaly immune
creatures oh God stop opening all the
doors if my door opens right
now no I really do think it happens in
fits and burst it like puts two in and
then it goes like find him oh what
was
that
whoa you hear
[Music]
that goodness
gracious spooky scary let's do a camera
check there's six cameras right one two
oh lights in
here 2 3 4 5 6 1 okay so all the cameras
are
up I think I'm starting to miss
stuff
I just get that feeling uh there was
nothing there
no oh the chair has been moved okay
that's that's definitely a thing okay
chair been
moved thank
you okay well that's one thing I'm
willing to about that there's another
floating around
here
oh someone didn't clean the sink for
their fellow passenger which is an
absurd thing to say you know when you go
on a plane you go in the bathroom and it
says please wipe down the sink for your
fellow passenger is someone spraying
blood across it like I I would I'm not
saying the wiping it down is is there
but I'm like aren't you guys just
washing your
hands please tell me people don't think
that the sink is a urinal CU that would
be extremely
unfortunate
hello well there's been a distinct lack
of extremely crazy stuff
happening plant cup I think if I just
say that I'll get a nice grounding for
the rest of it plant
Cup oh God what is that what was
that
oh trying to something's going on what
is
that what the freak is that whoa oh oh
oh oh oh no no no no no no no no
no what is that why is the music like
that why you got to do that is this
because of the last hour or is there
something bad because it makes me feel
like there's something
bad I don't like it plant
cup deserve the a report for strange
ominous music often accus when I'm
playing horror games that the orchestra
has following me a little too
closely whatever it's
fine not worried about it just there's
never been music in these games
before okay light in the private
car that's fine it's minimally invasive
I
[Music]
guess that's it stressful you know this
is the first time when I've been playing
these games that anything like that has
occurred so far be it from me to assume
that there isn't something about to kill
me four pieces of luggage yellow no
extra seats or rows or stuff like that
everything good all as
well that one cupboards open signs are
the same that's still there that was
still there believe that's still the
same but I'm just
checking okay it's coming back I thought
oh my God no no no thank you no thank
you no I don't want any no thank
you man far if I
miss that and die from it at this late
stage I'm going to be really
pissed oh this this toothbrush and
toothpaste have been moved that's a very
subtle one but I could feel something
was
off okay thank
you hopefully there isn't another
extremely subtle one that I'm missing
plant cup trash can the
same I also do notice that there's a
there's a bottle of pills in the trash
can I don't know if that has any meaning
probably not but then again I don't know
the lore of this game I don't know if
there is lore of this game you know I
bet there is I I just bet there is oh
wait there's more cups in there than
usual that is another subtle one
okay at least I'm getting them that
might have been the only two really
subtle ones or maybe that was really
recent and I just only well that's a
dark ooze of Abyss in the war that if
that is an abyss I don't know what Abyss
is okay I think the in Inky Blackness of
nothingness would be an abyss come on
come on come on come on give it to me
give it to me give it to me give it to
me plant cup
I'm
[Music]
on hell yeah I'm the
best well there you have it the first
level of I'm on observation duty but I
want to see what's going on with what's
coming next and to give you just a taste
if you want to see more let's just see
what's going on Outlook manner evacuated
Hotel guests transferred temporary
lodgings after the staff made
discoveries that point towards an
impending anomalous event one of the
cleaning staff reported that during
their shift some of the decorations had
reorganized themselves while she had
glanced away guests reported seeing a
pale figure wearing a wedding dress
gliding through one of the hallways
incoherent sounds have been heard from
the corridors during the morning and
night and Footprints have been reported
on the ceilings well I feel like this is
uh important for me to
know I hate that I hate him I I don't
hate that nice lion
wow okay well this is going to be a pain
in the
ass oh my God
hello
Hi how are you
um you you just hanging
out you just you just staying at the
hotel for the night all right well don't
worry the oom loomas are going to come
by and take care of you so thank you for
that appreciate
you oh
what what's
happening something's
happen
what's what is what is
happening
oh
[Music]
uh-huh yeah H there's a distortion in
the lobby
some kind of
[Music]
distortion look it
good I did something well there you go
I'm so good at oh it was red it was
green and I noticed
it good
good
oh
hi you
good you
good that's great that's that's that's
really good stuff boo give me a fun one
why am I actually why do I actually
remember this stuff like this is the
first time I've seen this and yet I'm
not even paying attention to that stuff
and I'm like oh I know those paintings
flipped because I remember remember how
do I remember I'm not paying
[Music]
attention oh is that a smoke one that's
probably smoke hold on oh never
mind damn I'm
good is that a pile of poop is that a is
that a poop pile someone poop on the
floor there is that a pile poop was that
a pile
poop
that that's
different
Hello I think this is just people are in
here I don't think anything of the stuff
going on here is just the guests are
coming in and out and honestly I
shouldn't be looking through the cameras
and honestly again wait I just it just
hit my brain there's a camera in the
hotel room that
that it's not good Ault
Jack
woo make Jack D boy it's The Shining
reference oh deniable anger bargaining
depression acceptance oh you think
you're so clever oh you think you're so
smart I'm going to accidentally win this
I'm going to unintentionally win this
there all right light you don't have to
be
that pointed at me you don't have to do
it like that that's a little mean rude
oh thank you thank you very much that's
a little
different maybe maybe I'm
crazy nope I was not crazy my instincts
are so
sharp I don't know why I thought the
road was
different I was not
it's not even going to give me a fun
one it's going to make it's going to
drag me along all this time it's not
even going to give me a fun one this son
of a
son of a
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait
there there there there no no come on
come on let me let me let me let me come
on it's right there don't game over
me thank
you
is that light always
off probably
not oh my God hello um are you waiting
for
someone are were you hoping that it'd be
someone else here or
uh sorry um
uh I don't care if you're trying to
sleep under the bed for
privacy we here at the Overlook Hotel
sleep on the
bed rules are rule rules what happened
you see that
something what is happening why am I am
I my eyes breaking what's
happening I don't know what's going on
something was weird
there all right nothing was weird at all
ever
wait a minute now hold on a second
here no no I don't think
so oh you silly billies you can't swap
your cars even though that's a perfectly
normal thing to do don't do that I I
have no idea why I'm doing so good I
really don't I was just going to pop in
here be like oh I Die game over and then
uh whoop-de-doo I'm too good
what I think that might just oh No
Escape oh well Frick come here
[Music]
you well that'll prolong me a little
longer oh hi how did I not notice that
why was that not immediately
obvious
666 oh
no well clearly
clearly
clearly I haven't hardly seen any camera
malfunctions or Abyss
stuff um which is good question
mark you know they were saying something
about seeing footprints on the ceiling
in the opening Scroll of this but I
haven't seen ner a single footprint in
the ceiling I haven't seen a
one so I don't know what they're talking
about this place seems the opposite of
haunted zero
hauntings perfectly
ordinary Nary is scrupulous
nothing
what what was that
heard something oh hey what's up there I
heard
you calling electrician I guess man it's
5:00 I thought I thought I'd be dead I
really did I'm not going to lie I
thought I'd be dead was there always a
piano there I my brain is never taken in
a piano being there but I fully believe
that there was a piano
there it's amazing where your brain will
just tune out
completely you know what no I'm not
going to tolerate
it I've come this far you can you can
have a drink at the bar I don't really
care but I've come this far oh oh my
God what do you mean what are you what
are you doing what do you mean what are
you doing what are you doing what are
you doing what do you mean what do you
mean what do you mean what do you mean
what do you mean what do you
mean
don't do that that again I seriously I
did not think that I was going to sight
read this one and yet here I am you're
going to pull that double on
me m- I ain't about it I ain't going to
let it happen you're not going to do it
to
me
go you
all right cool good great baby wait a
minute was there
always ropes there doesn't ring a bell
in my nog it wasn't that was not a thing
even though that does seem like
something that might have been there
just didn't check out in my
mind stop it you are bad at
that
leave
leave oh you better not screw me all the
way over here at the
end don't mess with me okay I've come
this far I'm going to finish this I'm
less than 30 minutes
away you can't do this to
me oh it's off the
hook
I swear I don't know why I'm not seeing
anything was there always a carpet like
that there is that a carpet always there
probably oh boy it's going to kill me
right here at the end of all these
things I
swear
you don't do it
please please pretty please pretty
please pretty please
leave us now no way no please this don't
don't don't don't don't okay all right
that might get me the last 5 minutes
I've been sitting here thinking like I'm
I died any second because how could I
possibly get it on the first try and yet
here I am so don't kill me let me get it
just let it happen let it happen just
give it to me give it to me give it to
me give it to me
baby
[Music]
yes well wow okay so I didn't expect to
beat that on the first try
ah I don't exactly know how to
contextualize this I I I just went into
that assuming that I would like get a
flavor of it just get a little sneeze of
it and and I thought I'd die right away
but I didn't I think I got really lucky
because all the stuff was pretty obvious
changes there was nothing terribly
subtle is there something at the end of
that
hallway but at the same time there was
nothing huge that happened besides the
guy at the bar so anyway we'll call that
a day we'll call that a day for now I
had another plan for that I thought it
was going to be a big old o and then I
die which is exactly what I'm going to
do now I'm going on I'm not even going
to read it you're not going to read it
where're not going to read this I'm
going to get this
goddamn you're going to see shush just
shush
yes lixian send them down that dark
hallway and then show them what's at the
bottom of it because they're giving me
SASS and I I I I don't take no sass so
you go yeah that's right you go goodbye
have fun down the hallway of
[Music]
death